[Music]
hi my name is Sarah - Vera and I moved
from Portugal to London to work with
Sammy Leeds in this episode you're gonna
learn about big energy equals a big bank
account so Samuel you how did you keep
that up I think I'm just excited about
what I do I only do things that I love
doing energy in you day after day hour
after hour I work with you yes and I see
you every day every hour and we work
long hours for the vanity yeah what do
you do I think partly it's a choice I
know that big energy equals big bank if
you have not got big energy you're gonna
lose you're gonna lose a business you're
gonna lose it sales
you're gonna lose again deals you can
lose a property what you always like
that in terms of energy um when do you
start feeling that energy and the levels
of energy do you that were important in
your life well it's a combination of
things number one is it's a choice
so if I'm not feeling like having a lot
of energy if I'm if I'm at work and I'm
feeling like ah then I'll make a
decision to snap out of it that's one
thing second thing is I'm passionate
about what I do I love doing what I'm
doing I love real estate I love media I
love everything I do I love doing and
then thirdly is I put myself in an
environment where everybody's like that
the reason that we wanted you to come
from Portugal to the UK to work
full-time on growing the business with
us was because of your energy same with
everything when we hire people we hire
people based on their energy so I just
think it's just a massive for me it's
massive I'd much rather hire someone
here was great energy but their skill
levels aren't good then they have good
skill levels but their energy I just
think Energy's everything yeah but you
know I have rituals like I do meditate I
need to read a lot spend time alone to
recharge myself when I go back I go
and I just walked by the sea which
really empowers me to feel my energy
back yeah but why are your rituals what
do you do oh 4 star I know I know that
we as an office every every morning at 9
a.m. we go we stop we start them we
start the morning with a lot of energy
we do it damps we get in a circle we
have music on we throw balls we talk
about what we're most excited about
which I guess is as a business ritual
from up from up from a personal point of
view I just I just choose to think about
what I'm grateful for every morning
every night rather than a ritual is more
of a habit it's more of just focusing on
what the successes that we had
professionally celebrate success most
people don't celebrate success most
people don't want to toot their own that
is because it's very British it's very
nice you think it's cultural is that
single Portuguese people aren't really
bad at celebrating you think English
people are good at celebrating because
you work in an English office where
everybody is yeah but if you went to the
next-door office you would disagree you
think that English people are good at
celebrating because you go to our beds
you're in the office and I'm not doing
disrespectful I know you've been to
England outside of yeah but honestly in
England if you do if you if you into the
states the United States of America and
you're driving a Ferrari
everyone will congratulate you nice man
what do you do for a living how can I do
that if you're in the UK driving a
Ferrari the same they'll just call your
wanker European spirit yeah behind it
the same time yeah but all and then as a
result of that successful people don't
then want to be over the top with their
successes oh my gosh I just got a pay
rise oh my gosh oh no because then how's
that going to make everybody else feel
well forget that because they should
feel inspired and if they're not
inspired if they're jealous then you
wanted to track them out of your life
anyway so make them jealous that's how I
feel and that's what I people sometimes
don't let stare
but then some people are super inspired
but if you can't eat your own horn no
one else will and part of that I think
goes with the energy day yeah people
people might think oh they're over the
top and it's compromised because success
attracts success yeah so if you keep
reminding yourself of your successes
daily you know daily basis is a good
habit yes and you just keep on building
on that pyramid of success and much
success just comes along last month what
your top five success stories my top
five success stories wow what a big
question so last month was November ok I
would say I would say meeting James Caan
from Dragon's Den I would also say how
much of it is private so I don't know
some people last month you know about
this some ridiculously famous people oh
yeah a star star star star that reached
out to me and said can you mentor me in
property yeah I know we cannot talk yet
predict that for me that was like wow
you know that's a hole that would have
been people just said that was a pipe
dream even six seven years ago pipe
dream you're never gonna have like
that's a pipe dream so that was amazing
I also think on a personal level biggest
achievement it's not personal it's still
business it's just some of the hires
some of the new people we've got in the
office you know how bad you know how
badly I love surrounding myself with
awesome people you know when we hire
someone and I'm just like bang punch me
in the face like this person is
incredible and then we've had so many
hires like that this last month number
four is the hole okay I can talk about
this again it's I don't make you draw
all this privacy out of me okay so we've
got an app so we're doing something very
exciting on in the technology space yes
very new for very much
last month again come on talk about that
ridiculously excited about that fifth
thing I'm most excited about from last
month technically it was last month it
was last week but it was November was
the I might might my team the Samuel
leaves little crow of bullied me into
getting a full-time personal trainer
secretly because I know you are secretly
because they want us a personal trainer
so they're like seven if you get a
full-time personal trainer it will be
really good for you slash or save it for
us I think that's the psychology behind
it but hey it will be really good and I
know how much you love the whole health
because you've been going on about that
for ages so I think if that comes off
and as soon as this interview finishes I
am downstairs back into the main office
and I meet in with two personal trainers
they both want to come full-time
potentially
so that's epic crazy stuff yeah so
you're gonna help the personal training
actually the thing is okay here's the
thing
when it comes to health is I am one of
those people I'm either all-in on all
out yeah and when it comes to helping
people and inspiring people and YouTube
videos and branding and property and
making money and business I am all-in
when it comes to health I just I've just
I've just been all out really I've not
really I mean I did that when I when I
broke my leg I did kind of take a bit of
time to lose some weight because I was
told I'd never walk again and I thought
I'll be damned if I'll be a fat [ __ ]
I'll be a [ __ ] what I brought enough
I'll be fat that's bad enough a fat
[ __ ] so when I'm overweight and I was
told you might not walk again that's
when I just thought forget this so I
lost I lost asked like a couple stone
and I've kind of kept it off but I'm
still in it me D yeah I know we've been
so busy with the business the moving to
London and the hiring to staff all the
events you're doing more events than
ever yeah before I once I wanted to be
with you all the time tell me what do we
make sure I'm working out but I kind of
you know made a decision yes wait care
of your body I have I have and I've also
given authority to Valerie my PA to hire
someone and then make sure that they
make you happen so sometimes if some if
you can't believe in yourself or if you
can't do it yourself you can just pay
someone to kind of believe in you and
your behalf yeah I'm not saying you can
pay someone to get you a six-pack but
but it's the same with people up with
our students I wish that there was a
Health version of Samuel Leeds I will
kick people's friggin ass into becoming
successful
you know I will literally bully people
into being financially free I'll drag
them over the finish me do you think
that's the same theory for your PT to
pull you into yeah so what what are you
looking for a PT more mindset it is more
mindset it's kind of like finding out
your Truvy's and why and then reminding
you of that and holding you to account
on that if there was a Samuel leagues
version of me before health that person
would be so helpful to me and that
person would also blow up it's so needed
because most health most health people
are [ __ ] so why do you want to lose
weight I don't want to lose weight I
just want to be healthy why because
right now I got so much energy and I
love life so much and I'm literally I
can go onstage for 14 hours and I can
drive all over the country I can fly all
over the world but I'm 28 and I want
that same level of energy when I'm 58 or
what I'm 68
I don't know unless I stop unless I
prepare now for the future the worst
thing that could happen to me is when
I'm 48 if I'm like I'm tired man I don't
want that I want to be like I want to
feel like I thought now I think you know
and I never heard you say no you will
never hear me say well you might look a
bit down after being on stage for 14
hours yeah but you never say I'm tired
you just say I'm just going out for my
room yeah man but that's that's good
that you had the vision for the future
and you're prepping yourself you're
making a decision today becoming healthy
apart Will Smith when I see people like
Will Smith who's got the same energy
I've got he's got that cool sharper man
but he's fifth day and I'm just and he
looks better than I look
you know his body and stuff and I'm just
thinking I'm 28 Will Smith's putting me
to shame I want to meet Will Smith I'll
tell about her to see if she can make
the happen or Amelia I'm sure she'll get
well soon you know how badly I'm
inspired by Will Smith you know Will
Smith he's so cool he's wealthy he's
he's charismatic he loves people he's
inspiring he's humble I sure like you
yeah I love math I want to meet Will
Smith Will Smith if you listening bro
give me an invitation to go down to the
states let's hook up let's do some
dinner yeah of course
okay so why is the energy like the
energy is a big part of you yeah how do
you put that at your event how do you
use that energy yeah in your event so
people can actually profit from it and
get inspired great question okay I think
there's a few ways firstly people that
want to do property one of the things
they lack is confidence and because
they're that confidence they're like
energy yeah and the reason that
confidence is because they like
knowledge so what I do is I firstly
here's the the freedom formula of how I
teach okay number one is all tell people
how to do something so I'll give them
the XYZ bang bang bang here's a stack a
deal or bang bang bang here's how you
call a didn't speak to them in negotiate
below market value deal bang bang bang I
know just tell them how to do it and
everyone goes cool that makes sense and
then they were expecting me to like you
know tell them more and they're writing
notes down yeah it's easier yeah they'll
be expecting me oh yeah I like this
information that's my youtube videos on
YouTube you'll get that tell tell tell
but at the event it's very different the
events it goes here's a do it bang bang
bang now I'm gonna do it and then the
energies are all right now this is like
a thousand people in the room yeah
everyone is on you correct now I'll say
someone give me a strategy you know rent
to rent HMO lease option direct offender
give me a strategy in fact who's the
most skeptical person in the room
I can stand up give me a strategy
alright cool cuz it but now who else is
sue feeling super sceptic your who's
right okay stand up give me an area yeah
okay cool
you just said Manchester you just said
rent to rent bow you know I'm gonna
follow him what I've just told you
because anyone can tell you something
now I'm gonna do it live now some of the
energy changes in the room now suddenly
people are like wow this will be
interesting
right then I'll do it live pick up the
phone do the deal energy begins to
change people begin to sit on the edge
of their seats and all other security or
I won't are the wild roar lessons from
it but then thirdly this is the real bit
now you know what to do now you've seen
me do it guess what's happening and then
everyone gets scared right yeah no you
come up put them in partners or
depending on you know your turn now your
turn now and by the way we'll be holding
you to account and by the way and then
suddenly who they do it they've got the
knowledge which gives them the
confidence they're now doing it which
gives them the power and the energy and
then draw lessons upon that and I think
the definition of educate is not what's
the definition is to drop out of people
yes
so education so education is to draw out
but what do they do is course with
everything they can schools those
crammed in yeah crammed in that's the
dusty exact opposite of true education
education is to draw at school they ring
the bell they make you compliance they
teach you to be a very good boy and girl
perfect employee to retire in 40 years
on 40% of what you couldn't afford to
live on when you've been working 40
hours a week in topics that you may not
even be interested and it becomes
something so fun everything as well
teaching stuff that's actually
application them welcome teaching you
about like boring stuff it's like this
is how you do a deal right people know
no to our events and be bored no no no
so I think that's energy in the room
that's how it happens and then also as
well because I love your questions so
much even things like having good music
on so people calling the music pump in
and and people say to me you know are
Samuel because I'll get I'll getting to
do stuff sometimes I'll say you know
high five the person next year you know
I'd even like oh man just give me the
content yeah I don't want to do a high
five listen [ __ ] listen dick here's why
I pitched you a high five
because statistically the human brain
can only focus on one person's voice
regardless of how interesting it is or
have valuable lists for about 18 minutes
before the human brain begins to drink
like it does in schools so you human
brain will drift off and you'll miss the
content we're here for 14 hours into the
crash course the first day 14 hours I
need you to be with me
so probably every 18 minutes I'll get
you to do something maybe a quick steak
change it might give you five seconds
just to turn to the person next to give
them a high five some is super quick why
so that then you ready to learn and
ready to receive more you can fight me
all you want and you can build up like
this I don't like that here's the bottom
line the bottom line are no property
training company in Europe gets the
results that we get because of the way
that we teach so instead of being proud
instead of being worried about being
over the top instead of fighting instead
of being like I'm gonna be cool you can
be really cool and you'll be really
broke or you can be a bit over the top
and you can be really rich I think that
people get that you make people
extremely uncomfortable in your you know
and I think but but they actually do it
and then in the end I thank you yeah
because they'll no one challenged them
to become uncomfortable yeah
every just patch will about tell you how
great you'll yeah yeah how you what is
that to punch them fine it's probably
depression maybe it is how do we be not
too bad I'll be damned if on my
gravestone
it says Samuel not too bad leads come on
great stone to say I wanted to say
Samuel friggin awesome leaves Samuel
inspired hundreds of thousands of people
to be better some you who left the world
better than we found the world
yoga ready doing that Thanks and thank
you for helping me become the best
version of myself
you're my mindset coach when we talk
about energy a lot and people any you
know it's just people what is energy and
use everything everything yeah we rise
entity in the room so we our office you
know it's just a massive ball of energy
all the time even even yeah everything's
energy but people are very skeptical
skeptical and I don't talk about energy
with a lot of people just the ones that
already familiar with the terms of
energy yeah because otherwise you're
just talking nonsense right yeah so how
can you how can we do that so we can
actually affect more people yeah to this
new cultural wave that is growing yeah
well how can we how can we get people on
board of the idea so we can actually
explain it okay in a rational way yeah
makes sense I think firstly what I do is
I I tell people big energy equals big
bank because everyone wants a big bank
yeah every bank so and it's so true
and when people link actually me having
a certain type of energy is going to
lead to me having better results health
results me being more successful me
having more friends even friends if you
go to a party you missed a no energy
standard around like a freakin loser
guess what you're not gonna you're not
gonna have any friends no one's gonna
want to spend Tommy's not gonna make
people feel good you go to a party
you've got a good energy and you love
people yeah is this a track you have
tracked people so and you attract what
you become so I think rather than sort
of telling people you know our energy is
important and everything is energy as a
theoretical thing for people just to be
like okay
that's weird it's more like hey what do
you want in your life
oh you want more money okay you want to
be more emotional you want to get
promotions at work you want to get fit
body you want to get a thick girlfriend
whatever it might be you want to get
okay you're going to attract that and to
attract it you've got it
and to become it you've got to have a
lot of energy you could have the right
kind of energy because honestly
sometimes people
I will not want to spend time with
people they haven't said a word don't
walk into the room just the energy
straight om so I'm just allergic to the
energy of that person I know I don't
feel the same I'm sure I've checked out
yeah it was that so harsh give him a
chance none of them did that to
themselves I have such a such a
repulsive energy so how do you clean
yourself from bad energy mmm - good
energy get around more people get around
the right people put yourself put
yourself in the right environment
environment is stronger than well power
don't beat yourself up I need more
energy or any more energy or any more
energy just put yourself around people
that are positive that want the best for
you there's also an energy in being a
caring person so you know when someone
doesn't want the best for you but they
don't say it I just got promoted you
know oh good that's not the response
response is amazing good for you you
know so people could say the right words
but they don't mean it they're back it
up with their energy you want to be
around people that actually have an
energy that's loves and supports you and
then also energy you submit to be passed
on Energy's not so when people say to me
I'm just saving my energy ridiculous
thing cuz cuz you know what's so
ridiculous because as you said what for
you okay what you saving it for what's
this big thing yeah you get married
tomorrow or something know what's
happening but here's the thing right
before an athlete goes for a run if they
got I'm gonna save my energy until my
one day then you're gonna you're gonna
suck at run day you need to stop running
yeah and in the same way people that say
I want to save my energy minima you need
to start practicing now because when you
when you start they said oh it's not if
when you become active what happens is
you then have more energy start when you
go to the gym I don't really go to the
gym because
it's gonna get really tight early you're
gonna go to the gym but you're gonna
have energy for the rest because that's
how this thing works
yeah yeah I agree completely agree I
think we very we need to be self
responsible as well for the levels of
energy that we bring to each room that
we enter meaning most people just like
oh I'm actually waiting for you to have
more energy even in relationships and
husband and wife is that if you don't
have too much energy
I'm just relying on you to have the
energy for me hmm and sometimes I think
we need to do the self-assessment and
see Oh where's my energy oh no no no no
let's push that yeah and then suddenly
you change you make a decision like you
said before you make a decision that
your Energy's high yeah and he will be
high and then at the end of the day you
just inspire more people to actually
become would you rather have a fiery
aggressive energy or an apathetic lazy
energy I'm the first one all the way
because I just don't relate to the
plastic one people say you know oh
you've got a bad energy they might want
to flip the cards on you are you making
me feel about no - use not a bad energy
my energy is actually a thigh reality
this making you have to do something
different I'm making you uncomfortable
yeah a bad energy is something that
makes people fall into apathy where
there's a good energy since the springs
people into action
yeah but also in love I used to
sometimes ruin the energy in the office
by accident
you know I felt that I did like let's
say you're having a meeting or
something's going on I'd come in not in
a bad way but you also need to be
sensitive because it's energies powerful
so if I come in in the morning I'm like
yo what's up you know hey let's do em
what's going on but you're actually
having a sensitive moment you having a
quiet moment yeah then I'll ruin the
energy yeah one mistake yeah so I think
you've also got to be sensitive about
everyone senousy about different
energies about different emotions about
what's going on I used to come into the
office I'd walk into court past 9:00 and
be like yo what's up man hey guys dude
hey yo your
and actually that's disrespectful
because people have just had a quiet
moment you had you've had your you've
just had your morning meet you and then
you've said right and you're talking you
have a sentimental thing and I come in
and people are in that I mean a
different and I just break into the
thing you've got to be you've got to be
sensitive and ultimately everything you
do whether if you're being aggressive or
or I say aggressive more like passionate
or you calling people have been direct
everything needs to be done in love
everything needs to be done in wanting
people to succeed in wanting people to
be better that's the key love love love
wins love wins
I have so much love in my bubbling in my
heart for so many people I just call
people up randomly just like you know
how much I love you that's how much love
I have I'm at the same with you Sarah
I'm at I call you in just a cells much
gorgeous decide oh so many times and you
always make me cry sometimes he makes a
video about something that happened in
it just yeah sense media video and I'm
like meditating or something and then I
just look at it and he's always like a
gratitude type of thing that he makes me
feel he always comes in the right moment
and I don't believe in coincidence yeah
right so it's like the energy for me is
telepathic in this in the sense that we
all want we all connected as a whole
yeah right yeah and so when you in the
same frequency and I kind of feel like
we all our business it's just you give
me whatever I need at that moment in
time I feel like I give another person
whatever they need at that moment in
time even if it's just a hug or just so
well done I was amazing it costs nothing
but you know what I actually feel like I
gained more they're not actually giving
to that person yeah I know some aches to
give a feel good yeah better to give
them to be seen amazing you know what
though everybody waits until somebody's
dead before they tell that person how
much they love them how great they were
and I just don't believe in that why
wait until someone's dead to say that
person was fantastic there's how they
impacted my life do you think that is
III think it's again as a cultural thing
it's
people feel so uncomfortable saying hey
you're awesome man and then so what's
the austere agenda there's no agenda
I just got it bubbly in my heart and I
needed to say I love you you're amazing
ly but I think it's cultural people wait
until people are dead before they say it
and I'm not about that I just wanted to
tell people up front I heard people
that's my thing I just heard people you
know they come to the office and we
interview them what I was like we heard
us here so what if they're not
what if they're not a hugger how does
that so funny he was like just keep out
just keep going you okay
I'm just hugging you funny though
because you are very welcome Jude you
have a very good etiquette you know all
about that kind of stuff I warn people
in that case I feel like that's just
going to be a cultural shock I go like
I'm gonna shake my hand coaches you
can't even shake now I'm gonna push you
and I'm gonna hug you yeah yeah and you
can feel the muscles of the other person
going like oh okay this is okay this is
what you do here okay if you're
culturally aware but you choose to break
it that's one thing yeah yeah when
you're ignorant as to what the glaze you
can't even I don't think I could do that
to your Queen know sometimes we two
bound up in what's more socially
acceptable in culture and C and we know
I mean for instance even celebrating
your success goes back goes back to
being PC I don't want to offend anybody
yeah you listen because you're kind of
reminding people that you're not
achieving that they spent too much time
trying to be liked yeah trying to not
offend trying to fit in people spend so
much time trying to do that and I just
think if everybody thought actually know
what my heart is filled with love for
everybody I love people I want people to
succeed but I don't I'm not concerned
whether people like me or not I'm not
concerned about fitting in I'm not
concerned about whether I fend people
I'm gonna be me I'm gonna I'm gonna
share my opinions I want to inspire
people I'm gonna be a giver but I'm not
concerned of anything else I think the
world would be a much better place so
sometimes certain cultures this whole
not too bad I'm fine
culture is complete
yes it's not like you don't care it's
just that you're thinking with your
hearts brain yeah really it's not like
you you let it go because your heart is
so big and you're just giving giving
giving that he's not that you don't care
about what other people will think it's
just that the cycle that you bring in by
just putting the love and just giving
yeah it just rotates and gives all the
abundance taking in too busy looking at
the even like on social media oh I'll
get some height comments but I don't see
because I just gloss over them but I
think most people if they put a video
out and they had a hundred comments that
well are you amazing this really helped
me thank you so much and then I had one
comment saying you know this was a
terrible video or whatever most people
would look at the one but why focus on
the one but when there's 99 good if you
haven't got the haters if you haven't
got people that are you're offending you
are not busy that's a habit you have
yeah you just focus on the positive but
you have to build that habit throughout
the your life yeah it's your habit and
also as well having good people around
me see I am my own worst critic okay and
I've got people around I'm hard on
myself you know I'm hard on myself what
do I say what did I even say this
morning the video that I sent you
I mean was that was that tapping
ourselves on the back saying we're
amazing what was that saying hey we
haven't got the date published on the
website for the next crash courses it
sucks we suck
let's like most of my business meetings
is me sitting down talking about how
badly I stuck and we sucked but that
excites me because it shows all the
potential for growth so but but the
thing is I've got people around me that
will tell me when I'm being bad when I'm
doing something that's not right you'll
tell me you do tell me
regular hey what you said then was rude
hey that wasn't good
hey you know that that's called being a
leader it's called being a friend yeah
and I've got people around me that will
do that that will say dude
you're out of line there hey your
content was terrible on that video
yeah but the like we tell you because
you open improvement you always want to
grow but the reason I had to say that is
because there's one thing which is
focusing on the positive and putting
your head in the sand in the negative
and another thing being open for the
negative being being being coachable but
at the same time not letting some
[ __ ] troll yeah yeah years old who
says actually your investment strategies
not going to work in 2020 because blah
blah blah blah blah and I'm like dude
yeah but also the feedback I gave you
for instance it comes from love it comes
from a place it doesn't come from a hate
and you just and it's constructive yeah
and it's how can we go to the next level
yeah oh yeah
sorry people around me they would do
that people who call me out people that
were even my pastor he meets me once a
month and he'll just tell me all the
things you know in love you know and I
friends I've directors in the company
they do that and that then liber8 Smee
to just kind of be positive and if I'm
getting hate from people who don't even
know yeah I've really I just don't even
know I just I just gloss over it I'm so
disinterested yeah no point just
immediate for me I'm not the best at it
at all at all but I think that that's it
I just don't
it doesn't feed me the energy that I
need to I get it from again hugs yeah
but and again if you if you do focus on
the negative No then what is gonna then
ain't gonna affect my energy
yeah the when I'm trying to help people
when I'm talking when I'm in business
means and I'm talking about how to do
the next multi-million pound deal my
headspace is in the wrong place
words of positive affirmation there you
go declarations yeah this is a big one
there Caressa you're really important
you do my event and I'll do them myself
why are they important okay so just
Rennie one that's thinking what the heck
is a declaration a declaration is where
you speak you speak to yourself
everybody speaks to themselves everybody
yeah even if it's a little voice in
their head
this is talk no good enough right you're
not gonna do it and for anyone that says
I don't have a little voice in my head
that's the little voice right yeah so
everyone has
little voices or they even speak
although are you an idiot why did you do
that you'll never ever catch me saying
that kind of thing
I speak words of positive affirmation
over my life every single day you know
yeah so and you trained yourself to get
there yeah you speak into existence yeah
and you become what you what you
prophesy over your own life yeah and if
you're constantly saying oh yeah whereas
if you speak with you speak words
because ultimately you can so what
beautiful sight of things do you say to
yourself even if it's just even okay so
it's not the same every day even if it's
just something like I'm about to go and
turn me in and it's Samuel you got this
you got this yeah you the man you know
that that speaking to yourself or even
if it's just a case of like let's say on
I'm going into something and I want to
inspire people it might just be a case
of you know Samuel you know you're you
are an I am an inspirational person yeah
I am an inspirational person my heart is
to help people my highest and I'm saying
this over myself it's true but it's
becoming even more too as I'm saying it
over myself you're putting the focus
your attention on that yeah and
therefore he expenses and even when I do
videos about what I'm gonna buy next
year in poverty this is what I'm buying
next year a company will turn over 100
million so you kind of mix that with
your goals oh I think the declarations
and goals
yeah you meet them together No yeah this
is Sam yeah Sam I do I do write for
instance that's one of the things I do
for since I do you shouldn't have too
many goals man just have a like four or
five things like people's people have
lucky to do this the beginning of
January big long to do this and it's
just so stupid because listen here's how
I do it I just think in 2020 if I was to
achieve four or five things what would
make that a friggin phenomenal year it
would just achieve two or three things
okay well maybe it would be to turn over
X and
my company to buy xml houses and then to
inspire X amount of people and see these
results or just whatever it might be or
I want to in 2020 what would need to
happen to fit to be a great year to quit
my job and go full-time into property
and to get my first three houses like
okay if that happened it'll be great
yeah okay don't think about anything
else this year nothing else matters
just that and if that doesn't happen you
die and every single conversation you
have on the phone every single business
meeting you have every time every
evening every spare bit of time
everything is got to be in line with
these goals yeah and then I think you
don't need to have a hundred things I
need to do list and then go and achieve
three and guess what if you have twenty
things on the to-do list and say four of
them are like oh yeah they're the big
ones you will not do those ones you do
the easy ones that you were gonna do
anyway of bit chilly and then you'll tip
them off and you think huh and in the
same year year after year you'll be left
not doing the big things account anyway
watch stuff wow that's really big but
only two or three things or four and
then but even that exercise is
uncomfortable for some people because
that means they have to even consider in
thinking outside the box and be
imaginative yeah tell everybody what
they are yeah tell everybody even this
list is what are this list is say to me
that's weight remember whether like you
can't tell people that oh yeah people
that's telling you that every day you
can't tell people that Samuel it's all
been advised by the best list is in the
country we just heard that just before
the podcast downstairs just did well
with Amory what did you say the same
sentence yeah you cannot tell people
that yeah we've stuff thought I'm doing
everyone all the time the best
consultants the best lawyers in the
country they're like I can't believe you
just said that you know or the elite the
rich and famous don't tell people what
you buy in yeah you pushing boundaries
and that's they don't like it they tell
me that it's wrong and
sometimes I have to listen to them
because I'm paying for them to advise me
but I'm just like my gut feeling just
tells me to tell the world my gut
feeling just tells me don't hide rustle
some feathers because the thing is
everything I'm standing for is is
actually empty the system yeah and it's
offensive because I'm telling people
that the education system is wrong the
government's wrong I'm telling people
that the universities and the elite
everything you set it up for people to
be poor and people to be slaves and I'm
saying this is the real way I'm saying
you know you're studying hard at school
getting good grades to get a good job
and then a good job for life the bottle
it doesn't exist and then to retire one
day I look forward to retirement because
that's where all the good stuff happens
this Conte this constant lie of society
this this that the strings are pulled by
the elite and and and it's offensive and
means that actually this is the true way
actually anyone can be financially free
and it's very easy you don't have to
have millions of pounds in the bank here
they become financially free it's an
offensive message and people shut me
down and even my success students that
become fine become financially free want
me shut down would you did you catch
that
yeah they become financially free and
there have become rich and then those
same people want me down they want to
protect ya whatever they gained yeah
because I think I've done it
salmon's do it he's helped me crash way
too much abundance in this world for
everyone I think you should start
charging for the crash courses now don't
make it available for everybody my god
you know don't make you free
don't say that on YouTube done and I'm
just thinking you know what I don't care
because I don't know what the
consequences of me my actions are gonna
be in my words me teaching everything
and me showing people people will watch
me become a billionaire and they'll
watch me and then I'll give them the
blueprint and I'll tell everyone how to
do it and and I don't know how I don't
know what the consequence of that on the
planet is going to be and and maybe I am
completely crazy and ridiculous even
speaking who do I think I am some as if
I want to change the world come on son
I'll get real used to working-class kid
to go but the thing is I don't feel
guilty because the job says those people
who are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are those that actually
so we'll see what happens I am crazy
what happens what my words watch this
space I love you so much
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]